[Music]
[Applause]
delicious
delicious vodka
glorious glorious
glorious yes
[Applause]
all right
happy glorious tuesday
it's our second night our second night
in dallas and it's even better so far
than the first
and it's not because cat finally bathed
or that tyrus shaved my back
i want to thank you for that by the way
i'll skin you later
we have a great crew tonight lara trump
is here
[Applause]
fresh
fresh from the masculist republic of
florida
why would anyone want to cover that face
i understand the view wanting to mask up
but not her
aunt jamie lissau has joined us from
anchorage
[Applause]
he uh
he can't
he can't see russia from his house in
alaska because his wife got it in the
divorce
so mean that was so i feel even bad
making that joke tyrus that was the best
one thank you
tyrus is with us he went out to dinner
last night to celebrate his birthday uh
when he blew out the candles everyone in
the restaurant got third degree burns
how dare you laugh at the
suffering of others
so
speaking of lots of crazy stuff going
around on the world and really it's not
fair to president biden or the democrats
for that matter you see after trump
things were supposed to get really easy
right the only thing that democrats had
to do was make sure trump was out of the
picture that everything was gonna be all
right there would be rainbows and
daffodils and sunshine and unicorns
i think i'm describing the sheets on
beta or works bed
[Music]
not that i'd
know it was supposed to be a return to
normalcy you know if you think it's
normal to sniff children's hair
in short
they didn't have to do anything
something they're usually great at
so imagine the surprise when trump left
massive problems arise that didn't exist
when trump was around
and i'm not just talking about joe's
word salads or pete budaje
getting knocked up
he's
he's gonna be a great mom
we're talking the biggest inflation in
40 years right the highest crime since
the 70s and not the 1970s the 1570s
i just saw a guy hold up a cvs with a
crossbow
if they start burning witches we'll
never see nancy pelosi again
red meat
[Applause]
and now like joe's diaper rash
that stuff is breaking out all over
in ukraine putin moves and moves troops
into the
don yet
people's republic
which sounds like ben and jerry's flavor
dog yes
here's a reaction on a russian political
show we call beat the pressure
[Applause]
it's like a smarter version of the view
so
look i know we should be concerned but
i'd be lying if i knew what the hell is
going on right i'm married to a russian
and i know nothing she's not even sure i
asked her hey what's going on in ukraine
and she says very pretty bird
all right
anyway so i asked my wife about ukraine
she doesn't know anything i said why
don't you know anything she says mind
your own business that she moved her
tanks into our spare bedroom
and declared it the people's republic of
do your own laundry stan
one thing i know i don't trust anyone
who claims to know what's going on or
what to do right especially mr magoo at
1600 pennsylvania avenue
i also don't trust anyone who cites
territories like don bass as if they
knew what it was an hour ago
it's like the guy who watches an earlier
airing of jeopardy and then pretends to
know all the answers
you know when the repeat comes on
tyrus
but that's cable news and network news
they read one article and suddenly
they're the experts but you'd learn more
from a segment on chicken kiev on the
food network
the funniest part russia took crimea
when obama was president and now
occupies ukraine with joe in charge
putin hopes kamala wins in 2024 so he
can take pittsburgh
when trump was president putin did none
of this
and it makes me wonder if this is
causing anyone at cnn to reconsider
their belief that donald trump was under
the thumb of russia
i doubt it they're too busy with brian
stelter's hourly feedings
you know it's so cute when they throw
the fish in the air
and he catches them
who knew you could train him
but we were promised so many things
right remember this biden classic
putin knows if i am president united
states his days of tyranny and trying to
intimidate the united states and those
in eastern europe are over
i'm going to stand up to him he's a
bully
okay cruised ship greeter
that aged about as well as pelosi's last
eyebrow lift
remember the good old days when we
didn't know what joe was saying but it
didn't matter
now it does matter and joe doesn't know
what the hell he's saying
fact is ukraine sucks but it's not a top
10 crisis plaguing america crap people
are in more danger at a weekend barbecue
in chicago
again we got inflation crime the border
and i mean canada's
we should roll our tanks in and liberate
ottawa
[Music]
[Applause]
i didn't know
yeah we could
we could make them part of the people's
republic of vermont
one nation under maple syrup
actually i do i use it on my skin for a
youthful glow and if there's any left
over jesse waters buys it from me and
uses it for hair gel
but let's not forget the border down
south if it were any leakier it would be
joe's bladder
too easy but maybe biden wants us to
focus on ukraine because he realizes he
can't do a worse job with that country
than he's done with ours
although by sending kamala there he's
sure making a run for it
i'd call her a disaster but that would
be an insult to the galveston hurricane
of 1900
but really let's really take a moment to
understand the significance of what
we're talking about
i mean let's really take a moment to
understand the significance of what
we're talking about it's been over 70
years
and through those 70 years as i
mentioned yesterday there has been peace
and security
we are talking about the real
possibility of war in europe
yeah i have no problem sending kamala to
a war zone the problem is we keep taking
her back
i kid
it's no wonder the dems predict a
blowout in the midterms all of their
lies of a post-trump utopia have turned
into a woke reality a dystopian chaos
where crime rises inflation explodes and
somehow we end up in war
you know all of the things they said
would happen
under trump
these people are more wrong than a
shirtless selfie of geraldo
yeah
huh
i wanted to wet your whistle with that
one
delicious but i guess that's trump's
fault too right
how soon before the dems say that hey
it's not our fault we won you guys
shouldn't have let us cheat
next time we'll let you guys count the
votes
i wonder what joe has to say about that
no no no look look
we're i'm not i'm not playing around
putin knows i'm serious all right
i'm not playing russian roulette you
know a game where they spin the wheel
and you have to take off your clothes i
don't do that he takes his shirt off not
me
and we're one for one me and him all
right he got crimea i got corn pop
yeah yeah
who's talking now
period
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guest
she's soap up
dado aurora promised to take her guns
fox news contributor lara trump
this alaskans act puts audiences into
hibernation actor writer and comedian
jamie lisao
[Applause]
you know
because her grandparents are in the
audience i won't mention her
debilitating drug habit or crippling
alcoholism
foxy's contributor cat tim
[Applause]
and finally they opened the roof at a t
stadium to give him head room my massive
sidekick and the nwa's world television
champion tyrus
[Applause]
[Music]
so laura
let's talk about your father-in-law your
father-in-law was supposed to cause all
of these things yes and it didn't happen
and now biden's doing it and they're
going to find a way to blame trump
though
well they certainly try every turn
possible but i think we know that when
donald trump was in office we were
respected around the world believe me
vladimir putin
would not be trying to mess with donald
trump i mean we were having trade talks
with china we had agreements signed all
across the world we were respected all
of it under president donald trump but
you're right greg everything they said
donald trump would do
joe biden is doing so yes a lot of
buyers remorse out there i'm sure but
isn't it funny 81 million people have
never been this quiet i know where are
they by the way
you know if he did
if biden is doing what they accuse trump
of they should try to pretend that it's
trump's second term
that almost made sense if you were
really high jamie
my big concern if ukraine falls where is
hunter going to get his next job
by the way that thing you just said made
sense to me
very high yeah there's so much to
dissect the the fight on the tv show yes
and i'll be honest with you i feel for
that guy like i was on i was just on
your show the other day with kellyanne
conway i know what that's like
and
she took you apart he did
did you guys notice the interpreter on
in the corner of the video where they
were fighting she just like doesn't know
what to do and she's politely sitting
there and i was like i wish i knew sign
language and i was the interpreter i
would i would have been i would have
been like
it would have been amazing
but dude that video the video of biden
obviously you said it it doesn't age
well yeah at all but then i was thinking
like what what does
you know what i mean like nothing age
biden doesn't age well yeah yeah that
didn't age well i looked up how old is
biden and just the tombstone came up
and um
that's like really old yes it is and uh
but nothing and then i also thought in
the article about russia and the ukraine
they call they said russia went into
ukraine with with peacekeeping forces
right i was like i don't know about this
language man that's like my wife when
she came at me with those helping
lawyers
for the
for the divorce papers and then i go to
my friends i go you guys have lost all
my money and they go don't worry about
it
you're aging well
it's so true you really are i'm amazed
cat uh so watching the news today
it's amazing so the people that were
experts on afghanistan seven months ago
are now suddenly experts on ukraine and
they pretend like they know i will not
pretend my my wife was born in ukraine
she grew up in moscow i have this is the
first time i've heard of any of those
territories i'm not going to go on fox
and pretend that i know what i'm talking
about yet everybody does this and
they're always wrong yeah i'm not an
expert no like if i had to lead troops
into battle i'd probably accidentally
invade the wrong country
but as a human right you know as someone
whose taxes pay for the war as someone
who has family in the military
as someone who's married to someone who
served in afghanistan and i've had to
see be very upset about what happened
there
i am very bothered by people having this
cavalier attitude about oh maybe another
war yeah there's another war like
because the people that make those
decisions and call for war they're not
the people who it affects the most right
[Applause]
how are you feeling pretty good
phenomenal excellent just so you know
you got two strikes i know i know well
did you enjoy your birthday i had a
blast yeah that's good that's good
yeah
um there is a feeling i think that
biden might just be over matched and
this was a guy who had like five decades
of foreign policy experience or
something and then everybody is reminded
that he never got anything right
no he might have fluffed his resume just
to scotch
now listen i don't i i barely got
through geography yeah
i know hustle
so he gets in to office and the first
thing that progressives do is they
end everything trumpian yeah and they
cancelled one pipeline which led to
russian pipeline that now supplies
europe with 35 of their gas
and they make a roughly a billion
dollars a day
so before trump went out
they were economically
strapped for cash right so you just gave
somebody a billion dollars a day
mm-hmm and all of a sudden they start
buying more tanks and planes and
missiles and it never once occurred to
you that maybe we should do something
about that now under president trump we
were the police of the world and we had
an iron fist
and we had
we had a really big gun
and everyone was afraid of that big gun
because the former president he also
liked big bombs it had you go bigger you
go home that's how we did it and the
world paid attention
biden got in and suddenly we became
english policemen where we yell stop
or i'll y'all stop again
he's gonna invade it's the beginning of
an invasion it's kind of an invasion
it's over
stop
yes
well
he was supposed to make america better
or what was it what was his phrase it
was like i can't remember what it was
now build back better he was supposed to
make the country better but he when you
think about gas he reminds me of me
how i treated my parents car when i got
a driver's license
he's just running the country into the
ground and then i didn't know that you
were supposed to put oil in a car
and he forgot
that we had to be energy and oil
independent
wow do you see how i wrapped that up
that's why i'm sitting here people
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else